あっほざいた
ん
ドクター始めです黒色嘘これが水たまりものも使ってるんですけどちょっと惣菜なん
ですけどやばいくらい黒いらしいんですよ皆さんの知ってる黒っていうのがテカってる
じゃないですか
もう影とが班外場そういうのは一切ない普通の黒とは比にならないくらい黒い出すん
ですけど一回何かに塗ってみましょうか
おっとちょうどいいところにマイメロちゃいましたね
早速だと1回塗ってみようと思いますまずこれがどんなものかを知られた始まらないと
いうことで開けます
まあ対立に入ってるのすいませんでマイメロちゃんちと何も気にせず
かけてみます
うぁああああああああああ
やばいやばいやばい
まあ
空母伊のでも
また流すやばいならもとか悩んでるみたいとかのに
[音楽]
f 2
じゃあもう真っ黒ですね顔出します
me
[音楽]
アイドルでご覧ください変わっていましただめだか
上げとして入試されるのはピントああああん若干て買っているところはまた乾ききって
ないところなんですけどもうほぼ
死ぬんよ塗るとこんなに暗くなるんですよいやもう普通に恐怖教布教区ここらへんまだ
乾いてないんですけど
ごめんよマイメロちゃん亜鉛っていうでご覧になりますでしょ
黒すぎるんですよあれこそが世界で一番黒いと飢えていると両国すくみそうでござい
ます
象ローレンドクターはずに思ったスライム2 gear の日本入れるやつ同案が黒色
場所でしたら世界最大に黒いブラック of か嘘じゃないので作れるんじゃないかと
思いまして
saas をぶつけてみようと思いますブーフ
準備あっという間では早速作っていきましょう
めっちゃ溢れっっ
さあ見たのはここでも始まります水と選択のにそしてその色にした絵の具とか食紅を
入れるんですけどまた施工で黒色メスを入れますそもそもここに入れた時とか混ぜた時
にどんな色になるかも知りたいですね
ちょっとまずは症状いきます
だーうう今日はクルーをまずだけ混ぜていっ
うわぁ
フロー
もんだが漆黒水やは一瞬で真っ黒なりますねこれ
[音楽]
多いなぁこんなちょっと指ただけなのにめっちゃ真っ黒すね
あどんどん進めていきましょうえっ
[音楽]
んんん
ていません
うわぁ
ううーーあそぼさはさああああ
できたなぁ
こいつがカーン
[音楽]
いやすすごいな動画で伝わるか分からないんですけど
すっ
イェイ黒いそれもなんか今回めちゃくちゃ出来がいいんですけど配分巻 p なると
トイレ皆さんこちらが世界繕いトロで作ったスライムでございます凄い存在感よ道が
あると伝わりにくいぐらいの空下がりますこれやばいこんなに黒イスラエル見たこと
ないましてこれだって薄めてるんですよあんなちょっとの量でこの真っ黒さ
強いはもう何ならマジで声なくあれだ
send 追尋に出てくるあの呪いのアレみたいなのボク経験上
スライムってちょっと入れて薄めてなんか透明できれいな発色になるのかされるなん
ですけども透明度かそういう概念がない
こんなちっちゃいの染まっクロスも色がで薄まらないんですよねこれ盾に世界一黒い
塗料って言われてるだけあるなって思いましたね今まで見てきたせない
の中でトップレベルに好きな色ですねすごくないだってこんなまっ体にプルプルしてて
めっちゃかわいいやめっちが会やこの荒野あーんか中根黒色武装なって持ってる人い
ないと思うんですけどアマゾンで買えたんでもしよかったら真っ黒のストライプを作っ
てみて下さい
校閲変えて欲しいかもよくわかんないけどねカナやんまりやっぱり皮膚に触れたら良く
ないっぽいこと書いてあるちょっと僕も早急に手だけは洗わせていただきます
けっこう薄めて a はいるなるデータ大丈夫だと思うんですけど皆さん子
同祭はお気を付けで作ってみて下さい
突然降ってきたら怖いだろうなぁ
値段これぞ
あっはーるへ行っは